how did you how did you end up getting
your dick stuck on stage
doing too much Molly was that it it's
really my fault I really think it was an
Illuminati secret agent just
destroying my rap career you don't think
you just have a sex addiction that's
never crossed your mind
I mean I think everybody have a sex
addiction that's what addicts say bro
exactly everyone loves alcohol when
you're blaming the Illuminati instead of
I need my dick sucked all the time let
me tell you to take us through it take
us through it so this day I mean you
know this is like early in my career
it's like you know I'm just not starting
to really get cracking like that you
know
and um so I got this show whatever and
I was at the time I was doing a [ __ ] ton
of Molly that was my drug of choice so I
was just doing Molly like every day so
I'm always horny and like weird and [ __ ]
so um
it was a lot of girls at the show they
were and they were feeling the boy you
know so but it was like like I would be
rapping and I'd be like on this corner
but like a group of girls and they'd be
like rubbing me like grabbing my dick
and [ __ ] and all that [ __ ] and doing you
know just being creepy but then I'll go
on the other side of stations like 150
year old looking old white lady and
she's doing the same thing but she's
going a little further than everybody
else
that's what I'm saying I think it was a
planet agent and this is the time I used
to wear I used to wear Rick Owens all
the time you know what I'm saying so I
had the long t-shirt to hang down to
your knees and [ __ ] yeah so you know
they keep grabbing my dick and [ __ ] you
know if the molly I'm like I think I
want to feel the real deal so I go back
to my DJ booth I just pop them up out a
little bit you know what I'm saying
so now I'm in front of the stage full of
charge
oh it's real
so then she just pulled the shirt up and
started doing her thing kept rapping oh
yeah I mean I I got to do the show I
mean I paid to do a job did you let her
finish no no the thing was it just got
so crazy it just was so [ __ ] up
because you got to think man there's a
lot of guys at the show too
and they were like getting smushed and
smashed and they were getting close to
the closer to the dick I was just saying
the look of horror on [ __ ] faces
what if Jason just grabbed this
you got it yeah so where you at [ __ ] so
I bring the [ __ ] I get her and I bring
her backstage she like I'm on my period
I can't do nothing I can't go nowhere
and then just left and she had like a
scary look on her everything about it
was just weird I'm like dude this was a
government secret agent that was sitting
here and what were you doing that the
government want to stop
I was too good at rap
that's that has happened with the
government before the strike on it they
got to see what is this weakness what is
his weakness let me show you how we can
[ __ ] this [ __ ] up they found it yeah
they got me they got you with sex yes
that's me I'm a real man I'm a real man
did that hurt your career that situation
I would say so how I would say so
because that was like the biggest moment
of my career so more people know about
that [ __ ] and they know about my actual
[ __ ] music like I was on
Entertainment Tonight or type
like I'm seeing all type of [ __ ]
everybody's reporting about it excuse
CNN all that type of [ __ ] but they won't
talk about my music or talk about me
normally yeah but but I tried to spend
it until I got sexually assaulted but
this is before the council stage so it
didn't really work out yeah yeah yeah
and now that I know that you whipped it
out first it makes it a little harder to
prove that point yeah
I don't want to talk about it no more
[Laughter]
you should have just made it your thing
you think that's a good point like
after that show I think I came to New
York maybe a few days later and you know
how you want to like get content and
[ __ ] and they was like interviewing like
people online and it was I remember this
one dude in line he's like
man I don't know who Danny Brown is but
if you're getting this dick sucked that
shows and he got [ __ ] like that in
the crowd I'm definitely pulling up so
it became this thing of where guys
thought the girls at my shows was
freaking crazy yeah so what happened was
I would always get these messages from
girls and be like Danny I love you I'm a
huge fan and all that [ __ ] I love your
music and [ __ ] but I can't go to your
shows the guys there are so [ __ ]
creepiest oh really [ __ ] up so it got
to the point where I wanted to I stopped
trying to make that kind of music just
to to not even you know so I don't like
rap about like getting my dick suck
songs and [ __ ] like I would like make a
three minute long song about getting my
dicks up but now I wouldn't do that no
more can't even rap about your passion
but now it's a sausage
now I go to my shows it's not one [ __ ]
you're back in prison that's what it is
ain't nobody braiding here though
there's no upside
at least they had good workout programs
yeah yeah soft Peter white lady tried to
do it what suck your dick the 50 year
old oh at the show yeah it was right
yeah it was a while it is oh bro she had
no business being there your first white
lady my first white lady yeah yeah bro
I'm from the days of Black Planet
what does that mean I would go on Black
Planet just for the white [ __ ]
explain Black Planet everybody
was a website for dating for black
people but every now and then you'll see
some white [ __ ] on that [ __ ]
because they want some [ __ ]
yeah yeah yeah I feel like that wasn't
real white girls though you [ __ ] the
type of white [ __ ] on Black Planet
they [ __ ] too
my status of getting a white [ __ ] like
these ain't real white [ __ ] these
[ __ ] just worse these [ __ ] dick
these [ __ ] EBT garbage
with an EBT card is dangerous and three
baby daddies that's all black oh man
I mean these ain't real white [ __ ]
man I gotta step my [ __ ] up yeah and
then when did you step your [ __ ] up
I guess when uh
I'll get that thing now now I don't
think you're a quality white woman is
because before you know you just
whatever you just doing whatever see I
was one of those guys man Detroit is
predominantly black you know everybody
will talk about interracial
relationships and all that [ __ ] not as
[ __ ] could be attracted to who
they attracted to yeah I don't know if
it's just something to me I was always
attracted to white women ever since I
was born I don't feel bad about it you
know what I'm saying I remember [ __ ]
driving past the Catholic schools seeing
that [ __ ] let out all them
[ __ ] come up with that skirt I'm on
the bus going to [ __ ] Sweden
House to go work wash dishes and [ __ ]
looking at that [ __ ] like one day [ __ ]
damn I have one of you
[ __ ] was always
crazy and then I mean like I said it was
a hard because you know as a [ __ ] you
got to start out [ __ ] fat white
[ __ ]
right right right why is that that's the
gateway drug because that's what they
that's that's what they want you know
you got to go with who like you first
yeah
like white women as a [ __ ] you ain't
got no money or a place to live yeah a
fat white [ __ ] is a goal yeah okay okay
so many coaches I've slept on
what these monkeys all that kind of [ __ ]
[Laughter]
I miss
what what race has the best sex what
race [ __ ] the best
I mean I I wouldn't know but in my head
I would think all the like um the Latina
Mexicans because
it's crazy for some reason I've never
tried I've never had sex with a Latina
they don't like me
I don't I don't live in New York that's
another thing too yeah but you live in
Texas
and I have I'm a one-woman man I have a
wife now yeah yeah yeah yeah but I do oh
you're married
trying to be
trying to try it
now you might have a wife one day so I
want to marry the girl that I'm with now
and then what's stopping you
financial reasons
[Music]
um
do I believe you yeah
like when I get the money right yeah
when I get the money right scam likely
but no
I do I I I'm because I'm done I'm old
right now man I'm 41 years old man like
you're out the game at this point it's
just creepy